do you know if scholars for dollars in
it I talked to one of my friends
recently and he said scholars for
dollars that's what it is that's what it
is
there's no and if you knew half of the
things me and a job that's gone free I
know times where he job didn't have
money to do shopping we didn't get paper
used for five years I woke up he jobs
trying to sell coals our lives in danger
we don't make money for me we got attack
left right center
yeah what are we doing it for I said I'm
gonna come over here to bomb sisters and
dear friends okay when we go into this
video insha'Allah got three minute clips
of sitting dinners video some things
they talk about misunderstanding some
accusation towards us I'm gonna clarify
that insha'Allah
also do not forget this check this app
this app is amazing you guys need to
check it shows you the nearest messages
towards you if somebody's doing jamar on
the road whatever you can get you can
see that on your you go you can see it
and go and join them if you go into the
to Jamaa people some people always want
to be picked up you can pick them up on
the way amazing check this app inshallah
now we're gonna lose promises as you
guys know hijab released a couple of
videos a couple of days ago and I
thought you know what
and at first I was like ah hi Jana did
you have to do it I figure Eight's
Ramadan etc but off these on the video a
lot of people came up to me and we start
bro people like very surprised and I was
like okay and it seems like they was put
out and I like this approach and etc
we're gonna do is brother and sisters as
you guys know brother sit and Dina yet
our brothers and sisters there are our
brothers and sisters yeah they say blood
is thicker than water
iman is thicker than blood yeah so when
watch the video in sha allah and we're
gonna react to we're gonna get to
straight away to allah and there's gonna
be things i'm going to tell you guys but
i didn't want to share before but i'm
gonna share with you guys inshaallah and
because also see new jobs with you I've
got bit encouraged and I thought you
know what maybe it's time that we do and
why were going to do it because I will
explain well let's just watch this and
sure let's get into a straight I'm their
internet drama though the dowel locks
died which affected basically both our
families and they affected us like an
extent they have no idea
okay the first part here firstly I
sincerely sincerely I want to make
something clarity please listen
carefully
I was systole acid Andina if you're
watching this I want to say something
very clear Sid has other previous evils
he said he's went from anxiety I went
through very very similar things as you
said very very similar things as you
brother and I might do a video
addressing how I got over that that's a
different story
but if what we did cause your anxiety to
get worse etc and cause some issues in
your family we apologize but listen
carefully we're sorry that that caused
that but we need to understand something
and we're gonna come to in a minute
that I am NOT here to apologize for what
we did but that indirectly
unintentionally if it caused you to be
upset
I apologize for your family for
suffering going through that but then
again you need to understand where we
was coming from his role but that's just
to clarify that point so apologise if it
had some kind of harm on you guys but
I'm gonna throughout this video I'm
going to explain why things happen like
that people saying she's no longer
Muslim and oh you as well no but yeah
first of all they came over to me but
then they started coming at you okay
firstly anyone that calls another person
a disbeliever because they take the
hijab off or their sinning is an
absolute giant ignoramus is absolutely
giant or it's a query you have to feel
somebody who does Edwards the Catholic
Africa for their on a mad one yeah so
that is absolutely disgusting and we
have never ever ever told anybody to
send hate swear dude fear of people ever
ever we've never done that from the
devil guys like really had receipts in
this podcast episode but we never ended
up putting out but we just don't forget
it get what's coming to them from God do
you know what scholars for dollars in it
I talked to one of my friends recently
and he said scholars for dollars that's
what it is that's what it is
there's no and I said to him what do you
mean okay
watch he's covered this I'm gonna repeat
the same thing but what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna talk about from my angle yeah
now seeing scholars for dollars that's
that's a that's a slander that's a
that's a big accusation you know that's
a big accusation because what that means
is that we are doing what we're doing
for the money now I could easily come
and say sit and you know challenge I
would come see you know you've been be
accounts me and AJ will be no accounts
yeah you look at our statements we'll
look at your statements yeah I'm not
gonna do that
yeah it's pity I don't want to go down
that route and I believe you know you
guys don't you don't grasp and
understand why I would it and I feel
like you're it's just guys it's too
bitter or maybe the egos in the way
where you're saying things why because
we just corrected you on a certain
matter you know and was that our fault
or yours we're gonna come to that but
scholars for dollars brothers and
sisters you've already heard this that I
do yeah it's not it's not something to
be hidden
yeah I actually recorded a video I'm
gonna release very soon in the car but I
had I had the Toyota Auris yeah the car
they belong to my house renting it to do
because I didn't have money to buy a car
yeah now and now I've gone in to show
Frank if there's anyone in the shore
industry I would really push it from get
in contact with me because I'm looking
for shuffling jobs so cut down my hours
at a bar yeah and another profit help me
was a car under law so I got a sure
thing car now Ruba I do
uber besides I've got two three jobs I
do uber outside of Salaam yeah Monday
Tuesday Thursday were at Salaam Studios
yeah Wednesday I do
uber all day Thursday after work
straight after Salaam brothers no I do a
bit till 3:00 4:00 in the morning 3:00
4:00 in the morning Friday I do all day
uber
Saturday all day oh the uber Sunday
before I go to the park I do in one
because I'm in debt and he job is since
he jobs gone and told you guys I'm gonna
need a break it's some family members
long story I hung in the detail but was
scammed
my grandma said they were scammed yeah
few people got scammed yeah and I'm
taking on that burden of that debt
because that was our life savings
yeah and I've took that on board and I
said grandma I will pay you I'm going to
I work and I'll pay you and there's you
other personal deaths myself is wrong
yeah I'm not gonna go to the figure etc
but I have personal debts and I'm not
seeing this too and I've seen from if I
want I could easily make this emotional
and this one I'm going through it cetera
if you knew half of the things with me
and he jabbers gone through I know times
where he job didn't have money to do
shopping he did not have money through
shot him we went through some issues
that happened in Salaam and there was
misunderstandings etc long story short
hamdullah a beautiful bond may Allah
bless him and a group of his brothers if
they have helped Salaam you know they've
helped a lot me Allah bless him and he's
very dear to me and I love him for the
sake of allah subhanho wa taala till
this day may allah bless him he knows
who he is in sha Allah I love him and
the brothers around they've helped us a
lot but there was a misunderstanding and
there was a time where he jabbed in our
shopping we had we had certain my money
we was thinking ok who can we help this
weekend who can we give it to this
prophet was suffering this etc like it
came - I don't go to detail yeah like I
know those times prophet sisters when I
do but sometimes I I fall asleep on the
wheel sometimes sometimes I and I have
to pull up yeah I'm not saying I drive
like that but when I realize I'm falling
asleep on the wheel believe me I don't
see in this to make I'm saying because
certainty now what the EPROM sisters
have a misunderstanding of pour this up
and I don't feel you know what I don't
feel any kind of animosity towards you
guys but I sometimes sleep in the back
of the car you will see me trust me like
you you will see me up in the back of
the car I have to pull up somewhere why
because my house is sofa because I do
but I end up all over the place unless I
end up all the way down South London and
I live all the way up north and I know
if I'm feeling sleepy
yeah and sometimes at nighttime I don't
have this no way open to buy espresso
yeah so what I'll do is a controller and
now we're not cuz I'm not gonna fall
asleep and I might crash I might crash
you know and there's been times
sometimes where I feel sleepy and I'm
looking and there's a bloody Club in
front of me yeah and once actually I had
a minor accident where I hit the kerb
mine accident yeah but I try my best
yeah I'm asleep I if I feel tired I
sleep now yeah I sleep in the back of
the car for two three I was sometimes in
the battle yes you guys aren't thinking
a lead our the YouTube our he does he
must have all this money he because you
just all you see is that apparent yeah
you just see something you don't see
exactly what's going on my mum gets
worried my mom calls and says look are
you feeling sleepy my mom calls me and
says look if you're feeling sleepy
take sleepy
take a nap my mum gets concerned and I
tell her mom don't worry whenever I feel
sleepy I take a little nap in the car
yeah so I do ooh boy I work I was I can
show you my app I can show you how was I
do yeah so yeah in a nutshell brothers
and sisters you need to understand
scholars were told it's a big statement
it's a big statement
Selam Studios we hear what you can see
around us with our own hands we clean
this carpets with our own hands we did
all these material all this here with
our own hands you know we got helped is
well brothers and sisters that's why we
race for some funds in Ramadan you don't
know Lisa just a financial that's what
we're talking about you don't know this
thing's if I told you you will be
shocked about me and a job in the TV you
will be shocked we can't we can't we
there's some things our families will
panic we can't and that's why we don't
see it you know sometimes showing things
that we get ya need sometimes I'm a liar
and injured employee like that sometimes
our life is a mutual danger when hey job
that's how we went to freedom speech
much what did we go there for for faith
yes yes I want to be famous
we went I was invited we got surrounded
by a group of mobs thugs criminals yeah
[ __ ] you would want to if they had the
chance they would kill every Muslim
these people they surrounded us hijab
were attacked I got took to the other
side where I was surrounded by a group
of them but they would wanted to kill me
you know brother and sisters and the
stories were I can give you many
examples I'll give you many examples
security measures that we have taken etc
our lifes are in danger we don't tell
you disguise you know because you don't
want to make a drama queen and you know
make it feel so we don't need no one to
feel sorry for us but at least Janna
don't for mother us yeah if you if you
don't want to help us the whole problem
but don't accuse us of such stuff as
scholars for doughnuts come on
and I and I don't want anyone to go and
attack them please one lie
don't don't all I'm just seeing this
you're mistaken my dear sister and
brother insha'Allah
so let's go to call this $4 and and he
said well you do all that people people
who do that type of thing and make money
for me make money from it they have so
much pride and it's funny because
apparently I'm the one who has so much
pride oh yeah it's so much pride so I so
pride I don't know I don't know I hope I
don't
I'm not gonna come in I hope I don't but
we did not do that video against our
sister Dina or yourself do you think I
wake up on the end just let me just do
I'm bored I'm bored hey don't just do a
video
I don't believe me we don't arrogant I'm
not at all I'm just like yeah whatever
my just go do your own thing leave me
alone
so funny because all of these scholars
of the internet internet that were guys
they want to bang on about religion blah
blah blah and they want to call people
out because of for the sake of the you
Thelma it's not it's not you are failing
first of all because of the pride that
this work is giving you subconsciously
okay now the thing is look either you
guys are right or we're wrong or we're
right and you're wrong you know we're
just looking from different perspective
Yani
if you think it people using for five
years I woke up hijabs tried this old
codes combs yeah they're not bad combs
here they are you selling combs yanny
how are we what are we doing this for
for what you tell us the money what
money
I work in uber so it's not for the money
the fame okay I can't come and see - no
I definitely I don't know my intentions
I try my best of rectify my intentions
every day to do it for the right reasons
yeah and like I said before sometimes
our lives are in danger I can't go into
detail believe me you'll be shocked but
so our lives in danger we don't make
money for me we've got attack left right
center yeah what are we doing it for
what is it you you tell us please I'm
calling tell us why we're doing it for
you know I don't know I don't know
there's a reason why they don't they
don't go out people or call out people
there's a reason for that
that's because it's wrong you can come
out come at me with all your quotes and
whatever is you want to say you want to
use a few big words that you picked up
in the dictionary just sound like you
don't we talked about you don't do there
you're wrong I'm sorry again Allah says
in the Quran let the rise amongst your
group of people who'll enjoin good and
forbid evil sister Dina you know from
day one me and Musa done a video you can
see the the actual picture of the video
here yeah well you said that you wanted
to take the hijab off but you leave it
on for the sake of
we did a video encouraging you if I was
there looking out for hey or whatever we
did a video encouraging you said sister
may Allah bless you etc you're keeping
on for the sake of Allah that's actually
we encourage you do you think I did this
to get cookies from you talking and what
did you do you tweeted the very
important day
don't tell another person's wife what to
do arrogantly I'm sorry we did a video
not that we wanted the AAA a cookie from
you you know nothing but to attack us
after we're doing a video encouraging me
I said no problem that's your take on it
etc you guys you know it's it go in
contact with Musa a general discussion
etc no problem then you did a video that
you want safely jump off
I did a video respond to that doing a
video general did I have a go at you
everything any job of did I say you are
this and you are that for signature did
I do that no I didn't I didn't know I
was actually praising you still I was
still crazy in a way well saying if
you're going for something that video is
for your audience for the sisters
because they follow everything you do
and I said look if she jumps out the
window you can jump out the window she's
going through that no problem don't take
any job off because there was a trend
going on with instagramers you know
that's why I even done a video you can
check it you can see on the screen where
I went giving my phone to Muslim girls
what was that I was saying sisters may
Allah bless you for putting the job on
in this hot weather it was boiling hot
last year from the mistake in here and I
was encouraging people not to take any
job off and then afterwards when we've
done that video you guys done a video
and you crossed lines you start trying
to see two sisters or work on a Muslim
woman marry non-muslim men it's Haram
still and oh you're making something
that's hella hot or something that's
Haram Hana so then what you want us to
just watch and you you're doing things
without understanding without the
knowledge yeah
then should we just watch by and let you
just misguided people and then when we
correct you all of a sudden we're the
baddies and we evil guys and we started
a and what you want us to do if we the
way we see every single one of our
promises as our own brothers and sisters
so if I see someone doing something
you're not the only you're not special
in that way I've done a video advise
them of Adam silent fuzzy troupe other
individuals I don't because they like
them if I do something wrong do the same
with me if
I see hijab misguided youth I swear upon
Allah I'm fasting I will do a video I'll
advise he jabbed in private and if he's
doing something public I would I don't
care cuz my religious my beloved to me
than any man-made hijab on your club or
well you unquote it we know our pulse we
know where we act up I know we wear Dina
after she knows where she met f double I
know where I act up as well and she
knows where where I act up as well but a
million percent we're not in the wrong
and wrong okay at least hamdullah you
understand the mistakes that was done
that's good rev define oneself now
seeing a million percent you're not
wrong the subjective did I'm not gonna
go into who's right or wrong
yeah we just thought that something
wrong we tried to really be and we just
got a attitude of you know like
self-righteous but again arrogance of
come on what we said to you know that's
all we did well if you're a youtuber if
you go irrelevant suddenly you need to
talk about someone who it's just become
relevant again just like you know I mean
relevancy is a disease relevancy is
disease we've learned that I've been so
stressed man in YouTube life and
Instagram like trying to stay relevant
one of the reasons that I considered
keeping my scarf on full-time was said I
could stay relevant okay now with this
issue now relevancy yeah so so what that
means it's basically in actually what
they're saying is that they're this
they're claiming that we will stay
relevant okay looking nobody's listening
to us and will become irrelevant I know
let's do something controversial and
then we'll stay relevant look some
people do this yeah now that's true that
is true if you and Sid did not do what
you did if you didn't do that we just
came out randomly you know how many
people message me black they swear in
their videos they do this do a video etc
I'm not look that is wrong but it's not
as huge another video are wise well like
even though it's wrong it's wrong how
many people miss her and I'm shaken or
them if I want I can say
any opportunity how many times I've said
I've even seen certain things that you
say which was in I just I just assumed
the best no no but when you say stuff
like why can't a non-muslim why can't
Muslim women married on was in men and
all this come on you know you want us to
just be quiet let me just do whatever I
like and then when we do it now we're
being accused of all you want to be
irrelevant it's not fair it's not fair
but I stopped showing our Muslim side as
much because we just couldn't handle the
amount of expectation maybe or judgment
the thing is you carry your on your
sleeve don't you being Muslim a lot of
people like for example the Dow a lot my
wall they just don't want us to speak
about religion at all of us much that's
come across like that no what we're
seeing is if you don't know something
don't speak about yeah don't don't don't
get into because you can make mistakes
and those mistakes don't come cost but
in general we would your Muslim identity
we would love for you guys as youtubers
you have an influence
we would love for you guys to talk about
Islam that is our you guys dude our yes
you guys you know we'll sit down guys
you're involved in so yes you are guys
is well maybe not directly but
indirectly you can do down with you
appearance you can it down with your
actions and your manners and your Huck
so carry on doing your dour carry on
don't stop carry on doing this because
it does work people and I'm sure a lot
of people start wearing hijab because of
you sister do you know yes there's the
low people you started with a job maybe
we can argue ok it's the wrong here I
whatever but it's that step towards
goodness you know but what would you
saying is inshallah that carry on do not
we've never said that we just do not
talk about might as you do not know but
you can't wait like if you're a Muslim
and you're living it it's part of your
life it's very difficult to just stop
showing your Muslim like slamming every
single thing we do every single part of
the day you're thinking oh yeah that's
enough you know what I mean yeah I'm
very happy I want in the video with this
year I'm very happy that sit and Dina
hamdulillah you know that he's lost him
and I said you know that's too nice a
job that makes us happy that makes it
happy that you uni mashallah you guys
are connected and hamdullah you love
this one
and I know you guys love Lonnie's
messenger yeah we know you can make
mistakes you have said things that were
wrong etc but let me tell you some are
given example at the first Olympia there
was a companion who would drink alcohol
and the companies they would with him
yeah they would whip him yeah to stop
and one day and he would carry on doing
this he would carry on doing this and
one day one of the companies next to the
Prophet peace be upon him spied cursing
this man started closing him and for
sell him stopped him he said do not say
that why Allah do you not see that
because yes he is sinning he is doing
something that's medicine yes he is yeah
but he lost Allah and His Messenger
he loves Allah and His Messenger
subhanAllah look at this in today's
times finally if we had these you know
some individuals a coke coke mentality
individuals you know yes is Haram you
kill it Oh God's sake yeah he said he
loves on one's messenger and we know sit
and even you love along his messenger we
know that we know that inshallah so it's
just a video I wanted to just clarify
this point in shava and make you guys
understand you might just see us as
youtubers and we look believe me you
don't know yeah holiday we and I don't
know me the last time I think when
holiday me and hijab and not a holiday
okay last yeah October and that was a
group of brothers who invited us they
invited us
yeah and they paid for everything we
wanted to pick like at least for food or
something they said no they did not
accept anything from us this iPad iPod I
have they gifted us iPads
yeah we went to check and they give to
those iPads we did not ask for it so
that's it Brahman sisters hope that is
clarified the messenger Allah may Allah
bless you guys thanks for watching share
to defend the family and yes and donate
help salami Allah because we are
struggling we are strong and we want to
carry on doing our work inshaallah what
we love doing the shuttle for the sake
of all aswan totally forgot except and
korean supports around the links gonna
be throughout the video
- next time ceremony better yet